a manova Krung a PhD candidate at Yale
School of Forestry and environmental
studies and I'm from mandu Nepal before
coming to Yale I was at in Colorado at
the University of Colorado Denver doing
my major in geography and GIS geographic
information system following that I did
a lot of work and community-based
environment health in Denver and also
did a project in Tanzania in relation to
malaria and climate change being born in
kolender and Nepal it has really given
me this opportunity to really look at
how this place is changing right like a
lot of population centers in Asia Nepal
especially Kathmandu is rapidly
urbanizing and yes it has a lot of
benefits to that but then there has been
a lot of problems associated with it and
one of them is air pollution and being
there and growing there I have been able
to see at a lot of visible signs of air
pollutions the ranging from the Greek
haze over the valley during winter time
people now walking everywhere with masks
on their faces and seeing all these and
being an environment student and wanting
to do something back home really made me
think like why not go ahead look into
this problem of air pollution and this
started my work in masters with my
traffic police project the traffic
police project in 2009 was looking into
personal exposure for both traffic
police and indoor office workers and
Kathmandu Valley at different locations
and proximity to roads we measured a
particulate PM 2.5 which is particulate
matter with aerodynamics diameter less
than 2.5 micrometers we saw very high
level of exposure for all our
participant specialty traffic police
given that they stand in the middle of
the road throughout their working hours
for them on average it was almost as
high as 50 micrograms per meter cubed
but that hourly averages would go as
high as five
hundred micrograms per meter cube and we
have to remember that the WTO guideline
is only 25 micrograms per meter cube
after my Master's project I was then
interested to know is like what has been
done so far in Kathmandu Nepal in terms
of air pollution and health
so I looked through whatever studies
that has been done did a systematic
review on it and found that there has
been very limited work done and
equipment in a part but but even those
limited work has shown that there is a
really high levels of air pollution in
this region and been really neat to do
studies in this region but then also I
want to talk about is also how how
important it is just do studies in this
region because a lot of times people my
question is like oh there have been a
lot of studies done in Western countries
and we know the relation between air
pollution and health
so why do we have to do one more study
in a Katmandu Nepal but then we have to
think about is like places like
Kathmandu Nepal have very high levels of
air pollution such that the the dose
response relationship that that was
developed for low pollution in Western
countries might not be applicable for
this area the pollution mixtures can be
different because of the various
different sources that is present the
exposure to the people can be different
just given that people have different
lifestyle and culture and finally the
health effect can be very different
because we have different baseline
health status different socioeconomic
status different access to health health
facilities making it very important to
do studies and commented about so my PhD
dissertation focuses firstly on looking
into the health effect of air pollution
by using hospital admission data and the
second project focuses on looking into
traffic exposure given that traffic is
the main source of air pollution for
Katmandu so the second project will help
form a framework also for future pizza
molecule studies because it will allow
to look into variety hotspots of
exposure in the valley what are the
factors like season how does that
influence exposure to the people and
also look into how does the exposure
vary by different subpopulations how
much is the exposure for schoolchildren
is
that in mind by where a school is
located by the where school is looking
in terms of proximity to road or the
neighborhood that the school is in the
big reason why we want to study air
pollution pal is because of the high air
pollution and because it is a very
understudied region at the same time
whenever I'm doing my work at the back
of my head I'm always thinking about how
do I take this information how can we
bring it to use because just doing
research research does not end by just
completing and writing a paper so I'm
always thinking about that about how we
bring that to policy so something with
my PhD dissertation that I'm looking
forward to doing is also looking at
different ways to disseminate the
information not through the formal ways
of journal and Conference proceedings
but also making some kind of an informal
document for government and
non-government organizations and also
working with different like partners
that I have now in Katmandu of how can
we use this information for increasing
awareness because ultimately you want to
take this information back to the public
and hopefully bring about a change the
challenges with our implementing our
policies and coming up different ways of
mitigating air pollution in command in
Nepal is firstly you cannot see air
pollution so it becomes very difficult
to actually convince people on the of
the effects of air pollution both acute
and chronic especially with chronic or
chronic effects you have the
cardiovascular effect the respiratory
effect the low birth effect and it
decreases the lifespan of people but it
becomes very difficult to convince
people that something that you cannot
see has all these effect on your health
also for place like that men do we have
various other problems like political
environmental which makes it very
difficult to focus on one thing and come
up with a solution the study the Nepali
government had a regulatory ambient
monitoring from 2003 to 2007 and it's a
very good data set we have TV measures
of pm10 particulate matter with
aerodynamic diameter less than 10
micrometer that is the biggest data that
we have for comenta but since 2007 the
monitoring has been stopped and one of
the ways that I'm making
of this data set is using it to
understand the health effect so it's a
retrospective study using this
regulatory monitoring data from 2003 to
2007 but and at the same time collecting
Hospital data hospital admission data
from 2003 to 2007 so we are trying to
use these data subject estimate what is
the effect of air pollution but at the
same time answering important questions
like how does the effect of air
pollution change by different sub
population what is the role of
socioeconomic status on determining the
vulnerability of the population which
regions in the valley are more
susceptible to higher exposure and
ultimately greater health effect and
also in the end to look into the effect
estimate how does that compare to other
parts of the world especially for
Katmandu I think we need to think in
terms of having very cost effective ways
of decreasing air pollution something
that we can do right now is remove all
vehicles have better road maintenance
encourage public transportation make
sure that we reinforce all the
regulations that we have present and
also maybe start doing the ambient
monitoring again because that allows us
to see if the standards are being
followed what the air quality is like in
terms of air pollution for Asia it has a
large proportion of the global health
burden and but if you look at what
studies have been done to relate air
pollution to health it's mainly done in
Western countries and the few studies
that has been done in Asia has been
mainly focused in more developed
countries of East Asia while South and
Southeast Asia where there's rapid
urbanization happening which means rapid
detoriation of air quality increasing
number of people living in areas with
high pollution areas has been largely
underrepresented for some something that
I'm trying to do with my work is also
develop a research framework so that we
are doing work in a cost-effective
manner
we are using technologies which are very
cost effective at the same time using
data that is readily available like
census data land-use data towards
understanding air pollution health such
that by this work we are also forming a
frame
work out how do we do research in areas
with limited resources at the same time
I'm also exploring different research
methods so that we form the research
methods that are applicable for areas
similar to Nepal so in that way I feel
like yes we Nepal can come and become an
example for other places on how we can
understand air pollution and health and
how we can mitigate that problem
you